I had to pick up something from you sir
because um it's um
I mean you are part of the DNA of the
you know the people in the world I mean
know all these melodies and I was
remember was 1975 was the first time
that I that I heard the school like that
I was still living in Argentina one of
the things I want to take opportunity
now to ask you because I always wanted
to know I I read that you use for use a
line of bases and you use tuba and use a
guy named Mickey Johnson I believe right
and but did make him play at an extreme
part of the register of the instrument
correct yeah and so that's something
that I always I mean it was funny that
you pick up the burner Herman because I
always thought there was a very
different but there was a parallel with
the the jaws theme with psycho theme
very different very different but still
very you know something very choppy I'm
not no pun intended but something the
use of the use of the use of silence the
use of an extreme register but hearing
in very different parts a very different
sensation provoking different sensations
in in psycho for me has something that
has to do with psychological horror with
something of a human nature whereas the
sound of the the the sounds of of those
jaws cues for me have to do with
something that comes like from the
bowels of the earth that comes really
from from something totally unknown but
that is part of of the earth and I
wanted to know I mean how how was that I
mean how did you came up with that
concept of taking that instrument to
that level at that to that extreme I
thought it was fantastic and the use of
silence and Milliman minimalism too
because it is very discreet
I mean they use you know so I was just
curious a what a test is I think very
right in my mind to talk the difference
between decide that psycho OneNote and
very high chose two notes very low but
human psychologic in in in the case of
psycho and the the challenge at least
for me initially to try to thieves ents
somehow this is a shark and the simply
the depths of the water and so on but in
the repeated bass note to try to create
something that was an unstoppable force
the power of the shark those two notes
will keep coming at you they maybe get
very soft at a certain point if he's far
away but then they get very loud if he
comes close to you so it is a very basic
and fundamental musical element to try
to ignite primordial fear of being eaten
in the depths if you like the suspense
as you talked about services if so much
of that sequence is Steven Spielberg's
editing also back and forth and so has a
lot of cuts in that you know right and
each one having to deal was having I
thought to be dealt with in a different
way I early on and still do have such
great admiration for Bernard Herrmann
who many of you will remember it's music
that I love to conduct that particular
scene seemed out more from from vertigo
and I think it was at least at the time
uniquely powerful in its expression it's
only a string orchestra is very simple